welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Marvel Studios really needs to
nail it apparently with a fantastic
forecasting a process that has generated
much speculation in recent weeks with
unconfirmed rumors about Vanessa Kirby
possibly playing Sue storm but really
what the hell is going on with this
movie Why has this been so difficult and
what is Marvel's plan for its Cosmic
future because I swear to God if the
Marvels doesn't give us any Shadows of
Galactus or mentions of Missy and saber
astronauts I I I guess I don't really
know what I'll do so in this video I'm
just going to break down a timeline of
everything we've been really hearing
about this movie and what it all means
how to look at it and what really do it
expect going forward reminder that
sag-aftra has informed us that
entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to cover movies
and TV shows like we normally do but we
do stand with the writers and actors on
strike to get a fair deal with the amptb
and you know what I think I have an
interesting update about what's really
going on with that right now but just to
remind everyone Marvel Studios Fantastic
Four film is being directed by one
division director Matt shackman and is
set to release May 2025 as of this
recording but to hit that date the movie
will need to begin shooting by January
2024 as it's currently the plan but the
actors Union is currently on strike and
while there has been motion by The
Writer's Guild with the mptp to begin
renegotiating a deal it could still be a
couple months before anything is
actually agreed upon word on the street
is that they are trying to come to terms
on a third-party auditor of actual
streaming numbers an independent group
that would be trusted by all parties to
compute that into Fair residual rates
for writers that way the studios
wouldn't be forced to declare publicly
to the press or to their own
shareholders what those numbers are
which you know it's totally stupid but
that is their position in their
apparently terrified if we know how many
people are actually watching these shows
alright then keep your Secrets but
anyway this same auditor mechanism
whatever it ends up being could
theoretically be used by the actors also
to get their Fair residual payments and
the hope would be that after that would
be set with the writers the actors could
then carve out their deals soon after
that but you know what it's still really
up in the air the SAG leadership has
signaled that they can stay on strike
for as long as it takes I can do this
all day and in the meantime despite the
strike these actors agents are still
hustling to Ink these deals and if you
think these actors aren't gonna look at
their phones and thumbs up a money bag
emoji let me know what anti-capitalist
pocket reality you're living in because
it sounds pleasant anyway for the
Fantastic Four film no cast has been
confirmed by the studio but here for you
is a timeline of the rumor train from
various online scoopers over the summer
they all claim to have inside sources
they all have slightly mixed track
records so I would just say take them
with a grain of salt okay here's what
we've been hearing May 27th scoop
account my time to shine hello tweeted a
grid of Adam Driver Margot Robbie Paul
meskel and David Diggs implying that
those four might be Marvel's picks for
Reed Richards who storm Johnny Storm and
Ben Graham then June 29th scooper Casey
Walsh tweeted that the Fantastic
forecast was still in flux that Adam
Driver was out that Margot Robbie was
out and David Diggs wasn't logged in
then on June 30th scooper Jeff Snyder
stated and yes I'm doing specific voices
for each of them because that's what
they sound like in my head I'm not doing
impressions of them this just kind of
helps me keep them all straight anyway
he said like I said it comes down to
money and so I think Adam Driver may
have priced himself out he may have just
started asking for for too much money I
don't know why then on June 30th scooper
Daniel Rick demand negative rpk said
that Vanessa Kirby was now being
considered for Sue storm and then on
July 10th Vanessa Kirby commented to
variety on the red carpet for Mission
Impossible dead reckoning which is one
actual quote that we can actually trust
the actor themselves she said this it
would be an honor it would be an honor
to play System yeah but look how fast
she was trying to get out of that
interview but anyway July 27th Joseph
Schneider said he said that Adam Driver
was never really engaged in this if they
had sent that out the script a while
back and he said that he couldn't
connect with the character on the page
and he passed her very early on then on
August 1st Cooper Danielle Richman
playing the rumor that Matt Smith was
being considered Marie Richard and on
August 2nd supported the Vanessa Kirby
rumors for Sue storm and then August 3rd
Jeff Snyder claimed with confidence that
he soon enough that he thinks Vanessa
Kirby will indeed be playing Sue storm
and he had heard the script will give
Sue storm a bigger role he also
initially claimed that Jack Quaid was
cast as Johnny Storm but he walked back
shortly before Jack Queen himself said
that he would not be playing Johnny
Storm and Snyder instead said that he
just heard the initials of the actor
were JQ now he took that to mean Joseph
Quinn also in his August 3rd episode of
the hot Mike podcast Snyder said that he
did not think Matt Smith would be
playing Reed Richards that it was still
an open roll and he said that Evan Moss
backrock would be playing some role but
not Ben Grimm maybe Dr Doom or Silver
Surfer someone who comes in at the end
he also cited a rumor that they're
looking for a Latino actor for Galactus
and then on August Night Daniel Rickman
said that now the script has changed and
at the studio actually went to
reapproach Adam Driver with it thinking
that now he might be more interested and
he maybe asking wait there's a rider
strike how could they have changed the
script Simpson well it's just possible
that what we heard about Adam Driver
when he was still in the mix were
reports of things that had happened way
back earlier in the year in 2023 and
late 2022. but who knows look it's a
mess but why has this process been so
messy well the reality is folks that
casting on every major release is
complex like this but only Marvel Julie
has this rabbit of a scoop culture that
runs with every drop of speculation so
that we hear about it and in 2023 the
media discourse with Marvel has shifted
you know According to some of these
headlines Marvel is at death's door and
they really need to get a Fantastic Four
casting perfect or it's all over game
over man this game over I honestly do
not think Marvel sees it that way really
I just think it's less common nowadays
for Studio to have to cast a full lineup
of beloved superheroes all at once for
the same movie and in this case these
four actors have to be right for the
roles they have to each bring star power
they have to have chemistry with each
other and uh they have to really be
vetted now now thanks to Harry's for
sponsoring this video and also thanks to
Harry's for majorly upbeing my Razor
game I used to waste time at the
drugstore just staring at the wall of
overpriced razors getting confused about
what I need now I just use Harry's
Harry's is a perfect balance of quality
and affordability I don't mind spending
money when I have to but you know save
me money when I can is nice too other
blades are more expensive than Harry's
but they're charging more because they
can not because they should Harry sells
their blades at a factory direct price
and it's the same price for everybody
there's no pink tags you're not paying
more for packaging or marketing you're
paying for what you're getting a quality
razor and Harry's is able to do this
because their blades are made in their
own Factory in Germany where they have
been making blades for 100 years you
don't need a middleman to get a great
shave you need a great razor so click
the link in the description below to get
a 13 Harry's trial set for just five
dollars and see for yourself thanks
again to Harry's for sponsoring this
video like when you look back at the
2015 fan four Stick cast they were all
promising upstarts they just didn't
really connect with each other and yeah
that script is pretty bad this time
Marvel Studios needs a 96 Bulls this is
why casting director Sarah Haley Finn
has been the unsung hero for Marvel
Studios and we always need to recognize
the work she has put in casting is an
incredibly difficult job even for movies
where you just really need to nail the
one or two lead roles when you're doing
it for a major franchise like Marvel and
the spotlight is Hot For The Fantastic
Four they have to create a family and
unlike the Guardians of the Galaxy they
all need to from the get-go be
multi-dimensional characters that could
each independently carry their own film
like the thing isn't like Dave Batista's
drags who could just play comically
stoic compared to the rest of them you
don't have a situation where you have a
rocket and a group who are basically
just bfx animated characters these are
four human characters and this has to be
a family that could have conceivably
already existed in the MCU the whole
time and and this is a really hard part
the front man of that group to
immediately come across to audiences as
the smartest brain in this world with
the wit of Tony Stark but also someone
we don't mind being that smug like with
Reed Richards and all Fantastic Four the
studio may take a similar route as they
did with the rebooted Peter Parker
sidestepping An Origin story which would
mean less time seeing that smug smart
ass suffer before he steps up as a super
smart superhero Now Matt shackman being
picked to direct this could support
rumors that this might indeed be a film
set in the 1960s the first two episodes
of One Division were set in the 60s
decade remember there was that joke from
Steven strange the 838 Reed Richards
played by John Krasinski Multiverse
Madness and you guys shot in the 60s but
again at the time probably just a joke
referencing that four groups like The
Beatles now while it's almost certain we
won't see the full Fantastic Four lineup
in the Marvels like they haven't even
cast The Fantastic Four yet and the
Marvel says wrapped I still think the
Marvel's film could set up the physics
that could establish the backdrop of
things like the Negative Zone and the
cosmic radiation that lead to the
Fantastic Four's power sets like the
veil that Kamala Khan tore open into
bypass space-time could be the same
means that the Fantastic Four use to
slip from the 60s to the present and the
relationship between the Bengals and the
cosmic radiation could be the MCU
version of the Nega bands and the
Negative Zone like if Cosmic radiation
is the same source of all the powers of
these characters the correct script
would be more of a sue storm story could
link her with the other three
cosmic-radiated Marvels from across time
and that could be why Vanessa Kirby was
cast first if that is indeed true we
could also look at the recent Marvel's
trailer where Carol Danvers was
described as an annihilator by the
character of darpin who in the comics is
a Cree General who made a version of the
Silver Surfer and the annihilators
it contains the Silver Surfer so I don't
know these could be Clues I could just
be grasping at straws here we may see
Nick Fury mention a quartet of some
saber Cadets who keep going rogue but
I'm not holding my breath I remember
they want a vision aerospace engineer I
think we all just went Marvel Studios to
get this right I don't care how long it
takes so it would be nice if they could
close these deals before d23 in
September because yeah that would be a
win that the brand I think does need let
me know your thoughts on all this in the
comments below please subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at eavos
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time bye
foreign
[Music]